IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY I DO THIS
EVERY TIME.
>> HARDWICK: TONIGHT IS THE 59TH
ANNIVERSARY OF DISNEYLAND
OPENING, YOU GUYS.
59 YEARS AGO...
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
IN HONOR OF THAT HUGE CULTURAL
EVENT, TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
DEPRESSING DISNEY. SO...
(GROANS, LAUGHTER)
EXAMPLES OF THIS MIGHT BE:
SNOW WHITE SUPREMACIST.
(LAUGHTER)
THERE'S NO TOMORROW LAND.
OR... MR. TOAD'S WILD RIDE WHILE
DRUNK KILLS TWO, TOAD WALKS AWAY
WITHOUT A SCRATCH.
FILM AT 11:00.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND GO!
YES, AISHA TYLER.
>> SNOW YELLOW AND THE SEVEN
URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS, GOOD.
WELL DONE.
HI, HO.
(LAUGHTER)
WIL.
>> UH, THE FUCK IT, NOTHING EVEN
MATTERS HORN.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
(LAUGHTER)
UH, KEVIN.
>> ROOFIE BEAUTY.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. GOOD. POINTS.
THE POINTS ARE... KEVIN.
>> THE LITTLE MERMAID HAS
MERCURY POISONING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
WIL.
>> IT'S A SMALL, SMALL
SUFFOCATING WORLD.
>> HARDWICK: WOW, SOMEONE WOKE
UP ON THE WRONG SIDE OF THE
FUTON TODAY.
POINTS.
AISHA.
>> UH, RACIST-ASS SONG OF THE
RACIST-ASS SOUTH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, IT IS.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
FINALLY SOMEONE SAID IT.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
IT'S THAT SONG PLAYS WHEN YOU'RE
GOING THROUGH SPLASH MOUNTAIN.
♪ HOW DO YOU DO
ALL WHITES THIS WAY... ♪
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
KEVIN.
>> FINDING CHEMO.
>> HARDWICK: OH, VERY DEPRESSING
DISNEY.
VERY DEPRESSING. POINTS. POINTS.
CHEMO!
(BELL DINGS)
WIL.
>> 101 DALMATIANS MEET MICHAEL
VICK.
>> HARDWICK: OH, WOW, NICE.
POINTS. AISHA.
>> OH, YES.
TIGGER AND POOH, A FECAL
ADVENTURE.
(LAUGHTER)
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> HARDWICK: UM, SORRY, AISHA,
WE DON'T SAY "TIGGER," WE SAY
TIGER-AMERICAN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> LOOK, IN THE STREET, WE SAY
TIGGAH!
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, HEY, I'M
SORRY, I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY, I'M
REALLY SORRY.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE THE
STREET IS.